نعم ، توجد البراغي النهائية في مكانها
في مصابيح التعقيم الموجودة على
الأرجح ، من المرجح أن توافق على أن الوضع الطبيعي الجديد هو
عودة الموظفين للعمل في هذا
العمل ، حيث يعتبر جهاز الكشف عن
المعادن جزءًا من سير العمل الجديد في هذه المكاتب
أعلى وأسفل
الفيزيائيين المبدعين فريد مكسيك  تدعي أنها
تستخدم الأشعة فوق البنفسجية بأمان لقتل البكتيريا
والفيروسات ، والفكرة هي
أنه يمكنك المشي فيها ، ثم ترفع
ذراعيك وتستدير ، وخلال تلك الفترة من 12
إلى 20 ثانية ، تقوم في الواقع
بإلغاء تنشيط الفيروسات التي قد تكون
على بشرتك.  ملابسك وشعرك
على حذائك ولكن هل يعمل حقًا
وقد يكون ضارًا ، الوقوف
تحت البوابة لبضع ثوانٍ فقط يكون
الضوء فوق البنفسجي سامًا
وتحذر روابط الأشعة فوق البنفسجية المتعددة من
استخدام الأشعة فوق البنفسجية على الجلد وهو مطهر
لا يزال هناك خطط مريضة  لبيع أجهزته
في أماكن العمل ،
فقد ثبت أنه ليس مادة مسرطنة
وقد ثبت أنها لا تلحق الضرر بعينيك ،
وبالتالي فهي
يقول علماء آخرون إن الطريقة آمنة للإنسان للاحتفاظ بها في بيئتك ، إن
الطريقة مشكوك فيها باستخدام ضوء
أضعف من أن يعمل إذا لم يؤذي
عينيك
، وأتساءل عن مدى قوته بالإضافة إلى أنه يقول
إنه يمكن أن يمنح الناس إحساسًا زائفًا
بالأمان أنك لست جيدًا
سيتعين عليك الحفاظ على التباعد الاجتماعي ،
وسيتعين عليك الاستمرار في غسل يديك
يقول كريستيان بينكستون إنه استثمر في
هذه التكنولوجيا لشركته على
أمل أن تحمي موظفيه عندما
يبدأ العمل في التطبيع ، أدركنا
أن الطريقة القديمة المعتادة في العمل
لم يعد العمل يعمل بعد
الآن وكنا بحاجة إلى NFA الذي أوقف
إنذاراتك استثمار Pinkston ، واحد من العديد من
maxixe الذي قال أثناء أوامر الوباء
أنه قد تم التخلص منه من الوحدات التي
كنا نبيع بضع عشرات منها
خلال العام الثاني  كانت الوحدات تبيع
بضع عشرات من الوحدات في كل ساعة تقريبًا
عندما تعود الجماهير إلى العمل ، يمكننا
أن نعرف أننا قادمون أو
نخرج من المكتب ونضيف التكنولوجيا النظيفة
تطمئنني ، ولكن لا تقضي بأي حال من الأحوال على تهديد فيروس كورونا من الموظفين ، يمكنك تعقيمهم من الخارج ، لكن إذا كانوا يتخلصون من الفيروس ويتنفسون ويتحدثون أثناء عملهم ، فسوف يجلبونه في الماضي الصحيح أن الستارة فوق البنفسجية التي يمرون بها وهم في طريقهم إلى المكتب وكأنني على استعداد للذهاب ، فأنا رجل جديد ، وتتبع جهات الاتصال هو جزء من العمل الاستقصائي ، وهو جزء من أسلوب الصحة العامة المستخدم على نطاق واسع ، ويعتقد الخبراء أن الاستراتيجية الرئيسية في محاربة جائحة فيروس كورونا يعتمد على تحديد ومقابلة كل شخص أثبتت الاختبارات الإيجابية عزله ومن ثم العثور على أي شخص آخر يمكن أن يكون هذا الشخص قد أصاب هؤلاء الأشخاص قد يتم بعد ذلك الحجر الصحي قبل أن يتمكنوا من نشر العدوى للآخرين ، وتقدر دراسة حديثة ذلك لأن شخصًا واحدًا يمكن للمصابين بـ kovat 19 إصابة 2 إلى 3 أشخاص آخرين ، ويمكن أن تتحول حالة إيجابية واحدة فقط إلى أكثر من 59 ألف حالة بعد 10 جولات من تتبع العدوى يمكن أن يساعد في منع  هذه الموجة المحتملة من
العدوى من أن تتحول إلى تسونامي ، إنها
طريقة شاقة ، لكنها نهج
يُنسب إليه الفضل على نطاق واسع في إيقاف السارس في عام
2004 بعد أن أصاب هذا التفشي أكثر
من 8000 شخص حول العالم
وقتل ما يقرب من 800 مسؤول في الصحة العامة ،
ويقولون إن تتبع المخالطين هو
خطوة ضرورية من قبل
يمكن إعادة فتح بعض الشركات ويمكن للأشخاص البدء في
العودة إلى الأنشطة العادية ، حيث تستخدم بعض
البلدان ، بما في ذلك كوريا الجنوبية
، والهند وسنغافورة ، تكنولوجيا الهواتف الذكية
جنبًا إلى جنب مع
التقنيات التقليدية لتكثيف برامج تتبع جهات الاتصال الخاصة بهم ،
بينما بدأ مركز السيطرة على الأمراض في الولايات
المتحدة برنامجًا تجريبيًا للتكثيف
تتبع جهات الاتصال في بعض الولايات ، تقدر العديد من
الدراسات أن الولايات المتحدة ستحتاج إلى
مئات الآلاف من العاملين الإضافيين في
مجال الصحة العامة قبل
أن يبدأ نظام تتبع جهات الاتصال حقًا في
جميع أنحاء البلاد ،
ومن المعروف أن kovat 19 يهاجم
رئتي الشخص ، ومن أفضل دفاعاتنا
ضد ذلك القيام  تأكد من أنهم
أقوياء وصحيون في
المقام الأول وللكثير من ذلك  يبدأ بالتوقف عن
التدخين أثناء التندب في رئتيك
لا يمكن عكسه.تقول المراكز الأمريكية لمكافحة
الأمراض والوقاية منها إن
هناك العديد من الفوائد قصيرة المدى عند
الإقلاع عن التدخين ، ومن أول الأشياء التي يجب
معالجتها هي الأهداب الموجودة في رئتيك ،
فهي تشبه الشعر.  الإسقاطات التي تموج
ذهابًا وإيابًا بينما يتحرك الهواء داخل
وخارج رئتيك وفقًا لمركز السيطرة على الأمراض (CDC) ،
ساعدت الأهداب على محاربة العدوى
وتساعد أيضًا على إزالة المخاط من
رئتيك.السعال يساعد أيضًا على تنشيط العملية
في الرئتين لإزالة المخاط وهو أمر
مهم بشكل خاص عندما  التعامل مع
فيروس كورونا الجديد عند الإقلاع عن التدخين ،
فأنت تساعد أيضًا في تقليل
الالتهاب في رئتك مما يسمح
لك بأخذ أنفاس أعمق وعدم
التعرض للرياح بسهولة على الرغم من أن رئتيك قد تستغرق عدة
أشهر للتخلص من جميع المواد غير
المرغوب فيها من التدخين.  التغيير
ستكون سعيدًا لأنك قمت
بإجرائه الآن د.  قال تشا الرئيس الليلة إن
الاختبار هو كلمته التي ارتفعت بشكل كبير ، حيث
تحدث عن 200000 اختبار تم إجراؤها يوم
السبت ، وهو يقول إنه ضعف العدد اليومي
منذ شهر مضى ، ومن الواضح
أنك كنت قلقًا للغاية منذ أسبوع أو نحو ذلك بشأن
الكشك ولكننا رأينا تحسنًا
هو  هذا هو الارتفاع الصاروخي ، هل توافق على
ذلك ، شكرًا جزيلاً
على استضافتي لإلقاء نظرة على أننا كنا متأخرين بشكل يرثى له
طوال هذا الوقت وأعتقد أن ما
يحتاج معظم الأمريكيين إلى معرفته هو
سبب إغلاقنا لاقتصادنا هو أن
الإغلاق بسبب  لم
يكن لدينا اختبار كافٍ وتوقفنا عند
150.000 في اليوم ، 200000 ليس ارتفاعًا صاروخيًا ،
إنه تحسن نعتقد أننا بحاجة
إلى إجراء 500000 اختبار على الأقل يوميًا
، وينتقدنا معظم الناس
لكوننا منخفضين جدًا يعتقد الآخرون  إنه
أكثر من ذلك بكثير ، لذا فهو مثل
تقدم معتدل في سياق عندما
تبدأ حقًا متأخرًا جدًا إذا
طرحت السؤال أين
تأتي أرقامنا مما نحاول
القيام به؟  قم بتقدير أساسي للغاية
إذا دخلت إلى حانة أو
مطعم ، فأنت تريد التأكد من أن الشخص الذي
يقدم لك القهوة ليس
مصابًا بالفيروس ، وهذا ما
نحاول خلقه مثل كيف ننشئ
مجتمعًا حيث  يشعر الناس بالراحة في
العودة إلى الخارج وتحتاج إلى 500000 اختبار على الأقل ،
ولكن من المحتمل أن تكون أكثر من ذلك بكثير إذا
كنت ستخلق الثقة
للأشخاص للمشاركة في النشاط الاقتصادي الأساسي.
الشيء الأساسي في
فتح اقتصادهم لفتح اقتصادنا ،
قد تعتقد أن الجميع في
البيت الأبيض
سيركزون على 24 ساعة في اليوم وطوال أيام الأسبوع.